you have to understand one thing about
directing that
every project you get involved in
ultimately
is just going to find its way to
breaking your heart
they say there are only seven stories i
think there might only be one story
we all understand stories it makes us
believe we can all direct
and we probably all can we all have our
own instincts what we have to do is
back up that instinct with something
called craft
i really want to demystify
the role of the director i'm going to
stage a scene and let you watch me work
with the actors
and action i thought today was a huge
improvement are you nuts
play to each other are you nuts okay you
know a set a beat of looking this way
i have the courage to face them a little
bit why i thought it was great is this a
moment of momentum and drive
or is this the conclusion of something
you know all these things intuitively
but as a director you have to move
beyond your intuition
there is no more powerful tool than
a great actor making a strong
performance choice
collaboration fails all the time
everything we do
in this process fails all the time
you're in this role as kind of
editor-in-chief
of a lot of ideas that alone will never
really make the movie work
we all want the same thing a great
moment a great scene
great movie this is what it takes right
ultimately you are the storyteller at
the end of the day
it doesn't matter how big your crew is
it doesn't matter how much money you
have to spend
it's what you're capturing inside the
frame lines that's going to have this
impact on the audience or not
go out find a story you love and tell it
very good work i'm ron howard and this
is my master class
you